يضلوا بالسجن حتى يعني ممكن عشر سنين ممكن
عشر سنين حتى لو حكم براءه حتى
تدمر اسمه مهدي على البراءه
كل من داخل هذا المهجى محكوم بالبراءه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم متابعينا الكرام اينما كنتم انا
طاهر بركه احييكم واقدم اليكم حلقه جديده
من برنامجكم الذاكره السياسيه نتابع في
سلسله هذه الحلقات مع مصطفى خليفه
الروائيه والمعتقل السياسي السوري السابق
اهلا بك معنا استاذ مصطفى مره جديده اهلا
وسهلا يا ابو القعقاع تريد ان تقتلني هل
تريد ان تقتلني بصفتك وكيلا عن الله في
الارض هل تستطيع ان تثبت انك وكيله ازلم
انك لست وكيل الله يا ابو القعقاع انت
تريد قتلي لارضاء شهوه القتل لديك يا ابو
القعقاع انما مساله الايمان او عدم
الايمان مساله شخصيه بحث الايمان هو علاقه
خاصه بين كل شخص وخالقه انت لست ربي لاقدم
لك كشف حساب مقتطف من رواياتكم القوقعه
اثناء المجابهه بينكم وبين ابو القعقاع
اكثر المتشددين تز متا ممن دخلوا المعتقل
اخذك وقت حتى استطعت ان تقوم بهذه
المجابهه
بعد فتره انقطاع تام عن الكلام
لماذا قررت ان تتكلم لانك شعرت بالخوف منه
صار في تهديد وجودي بمعنى
سابقا للمحاوله الاولى التي حاول
الشباب
المتشددين يعني محاصره هذا الشخص
وايزاؤه او قتله
بعد بالفشل نتيجه تدخل بعض الاطراف الاخرى
اللي موجوده داخل المحجى الشيخ
لكن مجيئ
ابو القعقاع ومحاوله استثماره
بالتشدد ودائما المتشدد يحاول ان يوجد
عدوا لكي يشد العصبه
خاصه في حول مجموعه يعني تحتاج الى شد
العصب
التنظيمي الطائفي الديني
وهذا غير خاص
بالمتدينين فقط انما كل فكر متشدد متطرف
كل المؤدل كل الجيولوجيات بالضبط كل
الايديولوجيات يحتاج الى عدوك كي يشد
العصب التنظيمي ويشد ويزيد اللحمه اللحمه
يعني بين اطراف
صار في خطر فاذا كان في خطر وجودي ولكن
اضطر البعض الى ان يحموك باجسادهم هذا في
البدايه في المره الاولى في المره الثانيه
كان في تحريض يومي
من قبل ابو القحاب بين صفوف المجموعه التي
تدين بالولاء له يعني او هي من نفس
التنظيم تبعه يعني بس صاروا يحرسوك يعني
بعض الاشخاص صاروا يحرس
نقسم الاحداث هنا بينك وبين صديقك
لا يشكل حمايه كافيه يعني
فكان في احساس بالخطر احساس بالخطر
[موسيقى]
ولكن عندما نتحدث عن هؤلاء الاخرين جميعا
من المعتقلين والسجناء هل كان معظمهم يعرف
التهم الموجهه لهم لانه في بعضهم شارك في
عمليات صحيح
بالعمليات العمليات مسلحه
واشتباكات مع السلطه تنظيم وعد فقط
الاطراف يعني في اطراف ايضا اسلاميه
متدينه موجوده
ما لها علاقه
لا تقبل
ناس طرق صوفيه طرق صوفيه مسالمه جدا يعني
ولا تميل الى العنف ابدا يعني بس حتى اللي
مش نشارك بافعال اجراميه او ارهابيه او
كذا يوضع في نفس السجن في نفس المهجه
يعني مجرد هو رهينه عن اخوه وعن ابنه او
عن ادهم ممكن داخل
نيابه عن المقلوب
ويقبض عليه مجموعه البراعم من هي
مجموعه البراعم
يعني طرفه هي اكثر في براعم
مجموعه من
اجساد ضخمه اجساد ضخمه
وطول
بدنيه العاليه
تحتاج الى قوه جسديه
البراعم هن يعني اطفال اللي بيروحوا على
الروضه
تهكما
وهيك يعني من باب المزح نعم مو اكثر من
هيك
معينه داخل السجن نعم بداخل السجن هن يعني
حتى عن طبع الاضراس مثلا تثبيت المعتقل كي
لا يعني عمل يحتاج الى جهد عضلي كبير يتم
الاستعانه باحد اعضاء مجموعه البراعم يعني
اللي يعني
نقيب البراعم طبعا
اقبع في قوقعه طوال هذه السنوات احاول ان
ارقب وافسر واسجل كل ما يحدث امامي ضمن
هذا التجمع الانساني رصدت الكثير من
الامور وفسرتها وسجلتها هذه الثنائيات منذ
بدايه تشكلها اثارت اهتمامي رقبتها
تحولاتها تطوراتها وفسرت في سياق الحاجات
الانسانيه للاجتماع والتواصل كل ما سبق
كيف كنت قادر بصراحه وباختصار ان تصمد كل
هذه السنوات ما الذي كان يعطيك الدافع امل
الخروج
لمحنا له الموضوع وتناولناه في بدايه
الحلقه الاولى يعني انه هناك مجموعه من
العوامل
تساعد الانسان على ان
يصمت اذا صحيح ولكن بعد اقصد بعد مرور كل
ذلك الوقت لانه نحن شارفنا على الختام
يعني نتحدث عن ثلاثه عشره سنه في النهايات
هل يبقى الامل موجودا هذا ما اقصده
الحقيقه مع مرور الايام يعني خبث الامل
يخف الامل ايضا
مثل ما بيقولوا باللغه العربيه الفصحى
يغرق في لجنه الياس شيئا فشيئا ولكن
بالاعماق بالاعماق يعني بضل
باخر النفق في بصيص صغير انه في يومين ما
بدي اطلع اتابع حياتي واتابع مسير يعني
هذا الامل يبقى موجود يعني وهذا ما فعلته
ولكن كما سمعتك في احدى المقابلات تقول
انه المعتقل يغادر السجن ولكن السجن لا
يغادره لا يغادر لا يغادره ابدا هو معك
حتى الان حتى الان يعني لم يكن بنفس لم
يكن بنفس الحدي غير المقابله
لا ولكن الذكرى او بالتعب النفسي حفر هي
ندبه موجوده في النفس الانسانيه تبقى
الانسان عايش فتره احيانا كتير يعني في
البدايات بتطلع من السجن في البدايه
هاي السميده حكيت عنها مره انا من اللحظه
هاي اللي بين اليقظه والنوم وانت تكون
نايم
وبدك تفيق من نومك
في هاللحظه هاي يعني بتحس حالك انه انت
بالسجن لسه هيك بدك ثانيه او جزء من
الثانيه
على معارضتك يعني الم يجعل كذلك تفكر يعني
بعد كل ما عانيته يعني من القطيعه مع
العمل السياسي
العمل السياسي بشكل منظم وهذا اصلا سوريا
في الصحراء يعني ما عاد حدا اشتغل عمل
سياسي بسوريا يعني ما في امكانيه موضوعيه
لممارسه العمل السياسي لكن كافكار كمبادئك
وهذا موجود يعني لكن لم يكن هناك اي عمل
على الارض
[موسيقى]
بدي اعيش حياتي وانسى هالمواضيع هذه كلها
يعني بصراحه القناعات لا تتغير قناعاتها
تتغير
تنقيلك بين السجون المختلفه
وتعاطي عده جهات امنيه مع المعتقلين كان
حضرتك او مع اخرين ايضا شو كان سببه خاصه
بالفتره الاخيره قبل الافراج قبل اطلاق
السراح شو كان سبب تعاطي عده جهات امنيه
وكل جهه تتفنن في الطريقه التي تستجوبك
فيها اه يعني هلا بكون في اسباب مختلفه
اسباب مختلفه يعني
لنفرض انه انا في بدايه اعتقالي الاول
في شكل من اشكال المناوره على التحقيق
ولكي اكسب الوقت واعطي فرصه
لرفاقي بحيث يتداركوا امر اعتقالي ادعيت
اشياء غير صحيحه وقلت انه انا ساكن بحمص
انا اعتقلت بحلب فقلت له انا ساكن بحمص
فهنا اخذوا اجراءاتهم وشكلوا دوريه وجابوا
سياره وكذا وبعتوني على حمص على اساس
يوديهم على البيت
بحمص وصلنا بحمص بالليل ما في مجال هذا
اخذوني على سجن اسمه السجن البالوني فنمت
بسجن البالوني هذا مثلا
خلينا نقول استثناء انك تروح على السجن
البالوني وتعيش فيه مثلا لمده يوم او
يومين وبعدين ترجع اثناء النقل مثلا من
سجن الى سجن شكله طبيعي احيانا هن بينقلوك
بدون ما يكون في سبب
بعد ما تخلص فيه نوع من التنافس بين هذه
الجهات الامنيه لارضاء راس النظام طبعا في
دائما التنافس ولحد الان في تنافس بين
سوريا في العديد من الاجهزه والاجهزه يعني
ودائما في تنافس بيناتهم يعني ودائما في
تكتم بمعلومات
تجاه الاخرين يعني يعني الامن السياسي ما
بيعطي معلوماته للامن العسكري والامن
العسكري ما بيعطي معلوماته لامن الدوله
وهكذا يعني ففي دائما هيك شغلات يعني اسمح
لي نتابع بعض الفاصل استاذ مصطفى الخليفه
المعتقل سياسي السوري السابق والروائي
السوري الشهير شكرا لوجودك معنا مجددا
مشاهدينا ومتابعينا الكرام فاصل قصير قبل
ان نتابع في هذه الحلقه ارجو ان تبقوا
معنا يعني هي عمليه اذلال
انه نتيجه السني 15 سنه
وبعد 15 سنه تجبرني انا اكتب لك برقيه
اشكرك فيها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا مشاهدينا الكرام الى هذه
الحلقه من الذاكره السياسيه
ونتابع فيها مع مصطفى خليفه المعتقل
السياسيه السوري السابق والروائيه السوري
الشهير اهلا بك معنا مره جديده استاذ
مصطفى
في الفتره الاخيره قبل اطلاق السراح كيف
يعني هل اصبح الوضع مريحا اكثر
بدي احكي عن تجربتي الخاصه هون يعني هلا
نحن رحنا على سجن صيدنايا وسجن صيدنايا
كان مفتتح حديثا ايوه
فكان في بعض الشروط تختلف كليا عن سجن
تدمر يعني بمعنى بمعنى تعذيب يومي ما في
ما كان في تعذيب يومي طبعا هلا اختلف
الموضوع صار اسوا شيء بسوريا وسجل صيدنا
حتى فتره الفن بعد 2011 يعني
اول ما رحنا اول ما فتح السجن يعني
87 نحن كنا موجودين في يعني لسه كان اثار
تشطيبات البناء موجود
فكان في تحسن بشروط الانسانيه
بيعطي شويه استرخاء عدا عن ذلك فتحوا
زيارات
فتحه الزيارات
صار بشكل منتظم تيجي زياره بس يعني حسب ما
فهمت بالروايه انه كان في معتقلات وسجون
خمس نجوم
يعني على قياسا بتدمر بهالمواصفات هذا سجن
سيدنا كان خمس نجوم
لان هذا المقصود على كل القصيده يعني مجرد
انه يعني فيك تزور اهلك يعني
ميزات يعني
تدمر
في الروايه
يعني نقطه مهمه عن رفض كتابه برقيه الشكر
للرئيس لانه سيطلق سراحك او صراح
صديقك احد ابطال الروايه ايضا واعتقد انه
هذا حصل مع
ربما مع المئات والالف العديد فكره الرفض
هنا من اين نبعث تحديدا
يعني هي عمليه اذلال
انه تجد الجني 15 سنه وبعد 15 سنه تجبرني
انا اكتب لك برقيه
اشكرك فيها
اي حكت عليها من فتره قرات انا كنت مقالي
عن كتاب لباحث ايرانيه اسمها شريعه
الطلقاني
بتحكي فيها عن
خلينا نقول دوافع الموجوده لدى النظام
السوري هو عن ادب السجون السوري وعن
السجون السوريه الكتاب اللي كاتبته الباحث
الايراني
فهي بتعزي الامر اللي دافعين اساسيين
الدافع الاول هو تحطيم الانسان من الداخل
بحيث يفقد قدرته في المستقبل على اي فعل
معارض لهذا النظام
والدافع الثاني لدى النظام
لهذه الجرعه من التعذيب هو ان يعيش
الانسان ذلا
يدفعه الى ان يكون مواليلا
بمعنى صحيح انه يعني كان يحصل ذلك لدرجه
انه احيانا يجبر البعض على كتابه هذا
التعهد بالدم كثير ناس كتبوا يعني يجبرون
على ذلك
وفي بعض الناس يعني
من
حاله
هلا في بعضهم اجبر لكن في كثير
يعني خلينا نقول نمط من التفكير
البراجماتي انه انا بدي ساويها وخلاص وهي
ما بتاثر علي ويعني هاي المنطقه التبريري
هذا يعني
بس انه انا بدي اخلص باي طريقه كانت
كما فهمنا من الروايه انه الاعتراف اللي
تستند الى الكثير من الحقائق انه الاعتراف
احيانا بيكون يضعف المعتقل اكثر
بمعنى انه بصير يطلب منه اكثر يعني مجرد
ان يطلب هذا في بدايه الاعتقال في البدايه
في البدايه عندما يكون التعذيب بهدف
انتزاع معلومات عن التنظيم اذا كان الشخص
هذا ينتمي الى تنظيم سياسيا معارض
في الروايه تتدخل العائله في النهايه
وبحكم نفوذ الخال لدى السلطه يخرج بطل
الروايه في حالتكم شخصيا ايضا كان في
تدخلات العائليه او عفوا
في محاكمات
محاكمات محكمه امن الدوله العليا الشهيره
بسوريا هاي سيئه الصيت ايوه
وانا كوني كنت من اوائل المعتقلين وقت
بدات المحاكمات كان مضيان علي اكثر من عشر
سنوات وفي نص القانون موجود انه ان لم
تحرك الدعوه العامه ضد المتهم خلال فتره
عشر سنوات تسقط بالتقادم فانا يعني استمرت
محاكمتي وقت اللي بلشت المحكمه كان صار لي
11 سنه بالسجن ثمره المحكمه سنتين حتى صدر
حكم بسقوط التهمه بالتقادم وطلعت شخصيا
حتى بالمده الزمنيه
شبه الى هذا الحد بينك وبين حاله صديقك
البطل الاخر في الروايه حتى في فرق بيني و
التشابه بين كل ما حصل لك وما حصل له هلا
في تطابق بالوقائع تطابق طابق الوقائع
بالتعذيب كذا مو بس انا وياه يعني كل من
مر بتجربه تدمر يعني
نفس الظروف نفس التعذيب نفس الاشخاص نفس
السجانين نفس مدير السجن نفس مساعد
الانضباط كله خروج من المعتقل كيف كان
شعورك وما اول ما اردت ان تفعله بعد ذلك
انا كنت مقرر لكنني عم نحكي عن احلام
الصغيره يعني انا اول شغله لازم اسويها
اني اروح على الحمام حمام السوق حمام
السوق الشهيره في سوريا حمام السوق بسوريا
البلدان الثانيه نفس الشيء بيقدموا لك
خدمه هاي الخدمه الخمس نجوم يعني بمعنى
انه في مليف واحد بيليفك وفي
يعني
اسمه الحمام التركي يعني انه انا اروح
بمعنى استرخي
لجو الحمام الحار والمياه السخنه وانه
استرخي على بلاط الحمام بس يمكن لما يصير
المراد موجود ببطل مرغوب
طلعنا مع الاولويات عدم تصديق ضلينا يعني
حاله عدم تفسيخ حتى صرنا خارج السور السجن
طلعنا خمسه سوا خمسه كنا محكومين بالتقادم
يعني
واصلنا بالشارع وشفنا في حاله انبهار كمان
بس ما بيكون في سعاده حقيقيه بالبدايه
ربما يعني في حاله تعويم التعويم
تعويم بمعنى
تحدد بالضبط
وكيف قررت المغادره
مغادره الى اين مغادره سوريا نهائيا بعد
عشر سنوات
من السفر
بالضبط عندما سمح لك يعني لماذا قررت ان
تسافر بدي تطلع القوقعه
وما في يعني ما في ما بتطلع القوقعه طالما
انا موجود بسوريا بس هالشي كلهن عكس بمعنى
على بمعنى او باخر على هويتك او على
انتمائك
نفس تعلقي نفسي
ولحد الان متعلق بشكل مرضي بسوريا يعني من
خلال ماذا بالمساله الوطنيه خلال مشاركتي
بكل النشاطات اللي لها علاقه بالثوره
واللي لها علاقه
يعني
مناهضه القمع والاستبداد
ومقاومه العصابه الحاكم
تعتقد بانه يعني انت اعتقدت منذ البدايه
بانه مع معرفتك بما يمكن ان يحصل في
السجون والمعتقلات كيفيه رد النظام انه
النظام لم يسقط انت كنت تقول ذلك منذ
البدايه
منذ البدايه يعني منذ البدايه كان ظل يعني
هاي تعرف يعني
فرق بين
رغباتك وعواطفك
محاكمتك العقليه يعني
بس انا كتبت مقال اسمه لماذا لو انتصر
الاسد كتبته باخر 2011 يعني خلينا نقول هو
نوعا ما
قراءه مستقبليه
كان استشراف لما يمكن ان لما سيحصل حتى في
حصلت انه ممكن نظام ينتصر
التاسعه وسبعه وثلاثون دقيقه صباحا اقف
على الرصيف المبلل بالمياه امام الفرع بعد
ان اغلقوا الباب خلفي واخيرا انا حر 13
عاما وثلاثه اشهر وثلاثه عشر يوما مضت على
وصول الطائره التي كنت على متنها الى مطار
عاصمه الوطن لكن للاسف حتى بعد عام يعني
وهذا كلامي انا الان على اطلاق سراحك او
صراح البطل ايضا في الروايه صديقك
يعني تختم الروايه قائلا روايه القوقعه
وتزداد سماكه وقتامه قوقعه الثانيه التي
اجلس فيها الان لا يتملكني اي فضول للتلصص
على اي كان احاول ان اغلق اصغر ثقب فيها
لا اريد ان انظر الى الخارج اغلق ثقوبها
لاحول نظري بالكامل الى الداخل الي انا
الى ذاتي واتلصص
هذا اللي حكينا عنه يعني
الزمن المطلوب حتى يرجع الواحد
يتكيف مع الحياه ويندمج مع المجتمع فيعني
بعد حتى يصل الى ذلك يدخل في قوقعه ثانيه
يدخل في قوقعه ثانيه يدخل في قوقعه ثانيه
يعني وتختلف من شخص لاخر قلت لك هيك عرضا
هلا قبل شوي طبعا انه بعض الناس كانوا
يرفضوا يخرجوا من غرفتهم يعني ما بده
يشتغل ولا قاعد غرفه
ما عاد عنده قدره على التواصل الانساني
فانت تحتاج الى زمن قد يطول او يقصر حسب
البنيه النفسيه لكل شخص يعني مختلفه من
شخص الى اخر حتى تستطيع ان تخرج من
القوقعه
خروج نهائي طبعا ما في خروج نهائي هذا كان
سؤالي لك هل خرج من القوقعه خروج نهائي
خلاصا جزئيا قد يزداد مع
مرور الايام
وتعقبه
وابتعاد ابتعاد
يعني الذكرى تبع ايام السجن وهل سنرى او
نقرا
قوقعه ثانيه ان شاء الله هل بدات بكتابتها
الحقيقه في هناك محاوله بس لحد الان يعني
ما انا حاسمه وفي بعض الامور ما ننبل وراء
ما الذي يجعلك تتردد بعد كل النجاح الذي
لقيته للاسف ولو على واقع ماساوي عشته
شخصيا ولكن بعد كل النجاح المبهر الذي
حققته القوقعه وكذلك رقصه القبور
يعني انا كان في دافع
بكتاب القوقعه كان في دافع عام ودافع خاص
الدافع العام او والدافع الخاص في البدايه
انه كان هناك شيء ثقيل ما داخل صدري
مثل عمليه البوح بين صديقين يعني الوقت
بكون هناك همه تبوح فيه لصديقك تخفف عن
نفسك يعني فكان هذا دافع موجود وكان في
دافع تاني هو ان انقل للاخرين للناس
ماذا يجري داخل جدران السجون
فهدافعين هدول هن اللي خلوني يعني اكتب
روايه يعني هدول هلا خليني اقول بصراحه
يعني موجودين
الدافعين الدافع الدواء في
وبعدين يعني
الجو العام اللي متعمد تعيشوا سوريا يعني
ومستقبل سوريا الغامض
لحد الان ما حدا يعني اكبر المحلين
السياسيين يعني سواء كان سوري او غير سوري
مانو قادر على التنبؤ بما سيحدث لسوريه
بلدا وشعبا وقيانا ولاجئين وارضى
كل هذا يعني يدخلك في جو من الاحباط
الشديد في
لشخص مثلا او لناس
قبضوا حياتهم في سيبيها هذا البلد والذي
يجعلك ربما تحزم عن الكتابه شيئا اذا
الدافع يعني
لحد الان ليس قويا يعني الفكره موجوده
ولكن
تجده
لك على كل هذه الحلقات هذه الحلقه
والحلقات انتهى التلفزيونيا ولكن سنتابع
مع فقره اخيره بقراءه من صوتك شخصيا استاذ
مصطفى خليفه على بودكاست العربيه من
رواياتك القوقعه شكرا جزيلا مشاهدينا
ومتابعينا الكرام شكرا لكم
ونلتقي على بودكاست العربيه وقراءه شخصيا
من الاستاذ مصطفى خليفه المعتقل السياسي
السوري السابق والروائي صاحب روايه
القوقعه الشهيره
والاسبوع المقبل حلقه جديده شخصيه جديده
من الذاكره السياسيه فارجو ان تكونوا معنا
[موسيقى]